quadrillés chaque centimètre pas à pas
six soldats russes des mines les rues de
marioupol
l'opération requiert du sang froid
chaque instant est décisive
la tâche est immense
l'ennemi a posé ses propres mines
terrestres
de notre côté on a également disséminés
nos mines antipersonnel bloqué l'ennemi
on a environ deux semaines de travail
devant nous
la série d'obstacles et désormais
évacuer les dernières poches de
résistance ukrainiennes ont quitté
marioupol les mines représentent donc un
dernier obstacle pour les forces russes
qui cherchent à contrôler la ville
portuaire depuis le début du conflit
plus au nord à kharkiv des soldats
ukrainien lutte contre le même fléau
c'est un obus de mortier il n'a pas
explosé il ya encore sa charge et c'est
très dangereux on va l'emmener à notre
base quand je l'aï réalisé
des opérations de déminage possible
pendant les brefs moments de répit que
la guerre laisse aux habitants de
quartiers
cet homme nous faut s'aventurer dans son
jardin je suis revenu parce que les
russes ont un peu reculé je voulais
mettre de l'ordre
assagi fait plus attention pas d'obus
chez le vieil homme l'opération que se
poursuivre selon les autorités
ukrainiennes des engins explosifs
seraient disséminés sur près de la
moitié du territoire les spécialistes
estiment qu'il faudra au moins 5 des
siennes pour terminer